-Welcome back, guys.
It is time for...
♪♪
"Tonight...Show" --
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-Gosh!
-Sorry!
-You on a time crunch?
[ Laughter ]
-He got places to go.
-I know. We got things to do.
I was gonna say,
guys, welcome back.
It's time for
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
♪ -Hashtags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Oh.
Thank you, guys.
Now, we do this thing every week
where I send out a hashtag,
and I ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
Since we are in the middle of
wedding season,
I sent out the hashtag
#WeddingFail,
and I asked you guys
to share the craziest story
from a wedding
that you've attended.
Within minutes it was a trending
topic across the country,
so thank you for playing along.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love it when you play this.
We do it every week.
So now I'd like to share some of
my favorite #WeddingFail
responses from you guys.
These are good.
This first one is
from @keepnitfun.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-They say, "The photographer
at my mom's wedding
backed into a candle
and caught fire.
My grandma shouted,
'Honey, your hair is on fire.'
My grandpa thought
she was alerting him,
took his toupee off, threw it
on the floor and stomped it."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Wow!
-That's a three-layer cake!
-That is like a -- That's
a Three Stooges movie, man.
-Nyah, nyah, nyah.
-This one is
from @jwilliams1027.
He says, "I officiated a wedding
for a couple
I had never met before.
It was 100 degrees
and the wedding was outside.
Just as the bride was
walking down the aisle,
my iPad overheated and shut off.
I had to do the whole thing
without notes
and/or knowing their names."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Uh, do you...
Do you take...
-Him to be her?
-Do you...
Do you take --
Right, what would you say?
What would you say?
[ Laughter ]
Yes? I d--
You would say -- No?
Ed? Of course.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @notoriousrw3.
They say, "At my wedding,
my best man started his speech
with 'You all probably recognize
me from the first wedding.'"
[ Audience oohs ]
-Oh!
Ouch!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's not bad. Come on.
That's funny.
This one is from @savageron.
-Ooh!
-He says, "My wife and I went to
a wedding and the reception room
had no tables for guests to sit
at, but there were chairs
still arranged in circles
as if there were tables.
So at least we could stare at
each other while awkwardly
holding our plates of food,
trying not to laugh."
[ Laughter and applause ]
I can't believe you sat me
next to --
No table.
-Where's the table truck?
The what?
-This one is from @tslouch.
They say, "A buddy got an invite
to his ex-fiancée's wedding with
the 'Will Not Attend'
already checked off."
-Ooh.
[ Audience oohs ]
Burn!
-Burn notice.
This one is from @jubjub315.
-Aw, I love jubjub.
-That's a good name.
-Jubjub.
-Jubjub, yep.
-What's up, jubjub?
-Not much.
He says, "As the best man,
I had to keep the groom
from getting cold feet, so I
told him that their relationship
was stronger than
specific couples
that were at the wedding,
forgetting I was miked up.
It got picked up
through the speakers."
[ Audience oohs ]
-Oh.
-Not necessarily you guys.
-Jubjub.
[ Laughter ]
-Jubjub in troub-troub.
That's my new sitcom, dude.
-Yeah.
-"Jubjub in Troub-Troub," yeah.
This one is
from @tomgall61097924.
[ Laughter ]
It's an easy follow on Twitter.
-Yeah, easy.
-How come you never
direct message me?
Never follow me or anything?
-Well, what's your handle?
I'll do it right now.
-Tomgall.
-Yeah? Okay, great.
-6.
-Wait.
-Tomgall61.
-61.
-0.
9.
-9.
-7.
-7. Okay, that's done.
-9.
-Okay, 9. Another 9.
My screen went black.
-2.
[ Laughter ]
-Hold on.
-He says, "It was my wedding,
and we had my wife
take a picture on a horse
with me holding it.
The horse got so scared of
my wife's crunching dress
that it just wouldn't let her on
no matter what we did,
so I had to jump on the top
with my wife holding the horse."
But he sent us the picture.
Look at the picture.
Ah!
[ Laughter ]
That's the funniest thing.
[ Applause ]
[ Laughs ]
Just cut the horse.
-Yeah, just get the horse out.
-Let's just cut the horse.
-We paid for the horse.
-Let's just not do it.
I can't have you on the horse.
[ Laughter ]
-You know who would have gotten
on that horse? Jubjub.
-Of course. Classic.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @marisarosie22.
She says, "My friend's
mother-in-law brought platters
of food to a catered wedding
reception so their side of
the family would 'have something
to eat that they liked.'"
[ Audience oohs ]
-Ouch!
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh. That is fun.
This one from @charliehenn.
He says, "To save money, I had
a cousin videotape our wedding.
The next day he visited the zoo
and taped over
the entire ceremony.
Our video consists of elephants
and orangutans followed by
a hard cut to the reception
with everyone doing the Macarena
on the dance floor."
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one is from @ashinrangani.
He says, "I gave
my friends weapons."
But then he shared the video.
Look at this rice
getting tossed here.
Ow!
Wait, there's one --
Look at this one coming up.
Boom!
-Oh!
-Oh, my gosh!
Congratulations!
So happy for you!
[ Laughter ]
This last one --
Oh, this is great.
This is from @jakewilliamsart.
He says, "Went to a wedding
where the best man thought
it would be funny to French kiss
an ice sculpture
with the bride and groom's name
on it.
He only got unstuck
after his friend
poured some hot soup
around his tongue."
[ Laughter ]
There you go, everybody.
Those are our
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.